bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rfo qu'est ce que vous avez
pensé de cette intervention emmanuel
macron ce soir qui parle je le cite
encore le qui parle du moment le plus
important de la vie de notre europe
depuis la création de l'euro
pour écoutez franchement pour nous il
n'y a pas grand chose de neuf dans le
plan qui vient d'être adopté parce que
en fin de compte c'est encore un plan
soit disant dead en direction des pays
de l'union européenne mais conditionné à
des réformes structurelles que les pays
devront mettre en oeuvre en échange de
cette aide
c'est franchement ce qui a été fait
jusqu'à maintenant ce cas le neuf c'est
que l'union européenne va emprunter
auprès des marchés et mutualiser la
dette
waouh pas excusez moi mais d'abord nous
attendions un plan à hauteur de 2000
euros c'était ce qui était souhaité par
le parlement européen on aboutit à 750
milliards d'euros et en échange de ses
750 milliards d'euros qu'il soit sous
forme de prêts ou de subventions
les pays devront mettre en oeuvre des
réformes structurelles travailler plus
longtemps réforme des retraites
privatisation de services publics etc
et ça on connaît et on a déjà vu et je
vous ai pas non plus les les rabais qui
sont accordées à certains pays du nord
notamment qui pourront donner moins au
budget de l'union européenne
ça veut dire que dans les années qui
viennent nous ont un budget de l'union
européenne qui va rester à à 1000
milliards alors qu'il était attendu
qu'il monte à 1300 milliards donc nous
aurons moins dead
au final de l'union européenne de part
son budget alors sur ce point que vous
venez d'évoquer mon avis évidemment
s'affronter les les vingt-sept justement
sur ces négociations être quatre jours
deux et quatre nuits de négociations
qu'elle quel est votre regard
ça montre quand même qu'il ya un
problème chez eux parce que tous ces
pays les 27 pays de l'union européenne
sont tous des pays de tendance libérale
et on voit qu'il ya un débat entre les
très libéraux et les moins libéraux sur
la manière dont on accorde cette aide
est comment la finance mais il y à un
accord quand même entre eux j'entends
parler de pays frugaux et d'autres qui
ne le sauraient pas mais au final ils se
sont tous mis d'accord pour demander des
réformes structurelles aux pays qui vont
recevoir cette aide est donc au final il
ya eu quelques tensions entre eux ce qui
montre bien que le projet européen est
en panne
aujourd'hui mais la même logique domine
c'est celle de demander des efforts aux
économies nationales et avec en plus ils
sont en train de mettre le doigt dans un
projet fédéral de l'union européenne
c'est à dire que ils ont même imaginé le
fait qu'il y ait un impôt qui soient
levés par l'union européenne auprès des
citoyens européens alors que l'impôt
relève du ressort des états et là ils
mettent le doigt donc dans une démarche
nouvelle
donc au final il ya peut-être quatre
jours de débats qui montrent qu'il y a
des différences entre eux mais on arrive
au même résultat sur lequel ils se sont
tous mis d'accord
alors justement s'agissant de l'unité
européenne
un thème cher à emmanuel macron le
président il évoque une grande victoire
du couple franco allemand
là encore votre point de vue
voit le couple franco allemand il a
toujours été d'accord pour mettre en
oeuvre cette politique libérale les
traités européens qui aujourd'hui on le
voit on fait beaucoup de mal à notre
pays a beaucoup beaucoup de mal beaucoup
pays de l'union européenne je pense
notamment aux privatisations en france
c'est la privatisation de la sncf ou
d'edf
je pense aussi aux réformes qui ont été
imposées à notre pays celle des
retraites celle de l'assurance chômage
tout cela a été commandée par l'union
européenne le couple franco-allemand a
toujours été d'accord sur ces réformes
très durs qu'on fait du mal aussi en
allemagne aujourd'hui en allemagne il y
a des des contrats à la tâche
regardez ce qui s'est passé dans les
abattoirs allemands qui a favorisé la
pandémie donc le couple franco-allemand
i s'est mis d'accord sur des traités
européens des politiques libérales que
doit mener l'union européenne et c'est
ça qui aujourd'hui fait du mal à nos
pays et que dont les peuples ne veulent
plus c'est pour ça qu'il ya ce fossé
entre les peuples européens et cette
europe qui ne répond plus aux attentes
on dit que l'europe est divisée
qu'elle avance en rangs dispersés il ya
quand même eu un accord même si c'est
vrai en accord au forceps les 27 ont
fini par s'entendre
ils ont réussi à s'entendre y compris en
étant un petit peut mener à la baguette
par des pays tels que les pays-bas qui
sont des pays qui en plus sont des pays
qui pratiquent l'optimisation fiscale
les pays bas l'irlande sont les pays qui
accueillent google amazon qui font ce
que l'on appelle des restrict fiscaux
c'est-à-dire qu'ils accordent à ces gars
phare de payer quasiment rien en impôts
et de ce sont donc ces pays qui ont
demandé à faire des efforts qui vont
demander aux français de faire des
efforts de rembourser cette aide mais on
marche sur la tête alors que ces pays
sont les premiers responsables d'avoir
de tous les états perçoivent moins
d'impôts perçoivent moins de recettes à
cause de l'évasion fiscale donc il est
vraiment temps que les peuples
reprennent le pouvoir sur cette union
européenne reprenne en main l'économie
n'est de leurs économies nationales mais
aussi l'économie de l'union européenne
une dernière réaction sur l'intervention
du président ce soir au journal de tf1
il a évoqué la situation des
agriculteurs dont les revenus d'après
lui son protégé pour les sept prochaines
années via la pac la politique agricole
commune est ce que vraiment il faut y
voir là une bonne nouvelle
c'est plutôt très défensif de la part du
président de la république c'est bien la
preuve qu'il ya un problème quand je
vous disais que le budget de l'union
européenne va stagner à 1027 milliards
d'euros alors qu'il devait passer à 1300
milliards d'euros eh bien
de fait le budget de la pac ne va pas
augmenter
or il était demandé à ce que ce budget
augmente pour mieux répondre aux besoins
de nos agriculteurs et donc le président
de la république est aujourd'hui obligé
de dire mais si vous inquiétez pas ça va
aller mais nous nous le disons haut et
nous avertissons dès maintenant ça ne va
pas aller et donc ce plan de l'union
européenne est un mauvais plan parce que
au final c'est nous qui allons le payer
les agriculteurs les français les
travailleurs et c'est pour ça que ce
plan n'a rien d'historique
il est catastrophique merci à vous
fabien roussel d'avoir répondu en direct
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes secrétaire national du pcf et
député du nord également merci